vous n'oubliez pas lâcher tout l'air que
vous avez pour certains c'est la
première fois qu'ils vont monter sur
scène devant un public
les enfants ont un peu le trac alors
pascaline donne ses derniers conseils
avant la représentation
je pense que ça leur permet
d'extérioriser ce qu'ils peuvent pas
être faire à l'école par exemple ou avec
leurs parents il exprime pas les choses
de la même façon
il aime beaucoup être avec les autres
faire un bout car une pièce comme ça
tous ensemble et tenait quelque chose de
bien à la fin de l'année
cette pièce c'est le petit prince dans
une nouvelle version revisitée où trois
comédiens différents vont interpréter le
garçon aux cheveux blonds en gros ça
raconte une histoire de trois petits
princes qui parle dans leur planète
ensuite ils vont visiter des autres
planètes
on a commencé depuis le début de l'année
on a fait une répétition que de la
première partie en novembre ensuite bas
on aurait visé à la 2e la première plus
on est prêt c'est sympa on peut exprimer
on peut s'exprimer comme on veut il m'a
fallu deux jours voie à prendre leurs
repères coeur je connais bien maintenant
moi quand j'apprends les relations
étaient très bas âge qui retient
toujours après en plus de cette pièce
jouée exclusivement par les enfants
l'association club jeune théâtre propose
dans le cadre de son festival
quatre autres pièces à découvrir
jusqu'au 22 mai